brian is with us in New York
hi Brian how are you great Davidson
honor to be speaking with you sir
you too what's up also I'm required to
give a shout out saw the YouTube crazies
ah
okay glow and also to Lloyd who called
earlier just wants to know all praying
for a say Amen I'm not over that my wife
and I are currently in baby step two and
she is looking to go back to school next
May she wants to ultimately become a
nurse practitioner I should have become
an RN first that's a one-year program
she's gonna have to stop school earth
stop working completely unless to rely
solely on my income can you do that
about a hundred hundred fifty thousand
dollars in debt
my income is going to be about 45 to 50
by itself it's her you know at school
full-time and we're thinking you should
save about 10 grand to supplement for
the year one hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in debt on what oh it's the lot
of student loans
there's credit cards car loans and of
course the KGB and how much do they
onerous it's down to about eighty six
hundred we've got to now I'll see in our
first year we had budget appropriately
for our calyxes well what did she make
it work as she makes about before taxes
today on how she works
about sixty i listened when you become
an RN your income is not going to change
substantially from sixty I mean it might
I want she becomes a nurse practitioner
which way would go up substantially cut
might be maybe there may be two eighty
to ninety but that's about it
and so you guys have a bigger problem
than
her changing careers right now as her
changing careers was going to raise her
income 100 grand or something it'd be
different but it's not
he told walk away from a $60,000 income
which is more than you make while you
guys are $150,000 in debt right now it's
just not logical I'm thinking of cleanup
your former decisions before you make a
new decision is what I would do so I'm
I'm not okay with her plan you know you
got certainly are adults you can do
whatever you want to do there's no
question about that if you're asking my
opinion at my house what would we do
know you've got an income right now
about a hundred grand you got $150,000
in debt you know I'm going to be
debt-free in about two years two and
I'll probably two and a half years and
I'm gonna pick up about a bazillion
extra jobs and try to make it two years
so that she can go back to school and
pay cash for that at that point but you
can't just walk away from over half of
your household income so she can go back
to school to make a few dollars more and
to change careers you're not in a
position to do that you've made a series
of decisions like that to this point
that have got you guys in this mess and
you're just you don't have the freedom
to do that you because of your past
decisions that's what it means when it
says the borrower slave of the lender
you're a slave to this mess right now
your slaves don't get choices they have
to listen to their master and you have a
150,000 dollars where the master right
now it's got chains around your neck and
so if I'm you I'm getting real pissed
off about that and I'm going to break
them off of me really loud really proud
really get after it and her too but you
can't just every morning wake up and go
I'm going to go do something else and
I'm going to go more than that and more
just go stop our income this is just the
the math that you're giving me just
completely illogical and so it doesn't
make sense to me again you guys are
adults you can do whatever you want to
do I'm telling you what we would do if
Dave and Sharon rimsey woke up in your
situation we would buckle down and clean
up the mess and once it's gone and we'd
save up and go back to school that's how
we've done our life and it's worked out
really well for us thanks for calling in
dude hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button too
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]